hi
my name is colleen fitzpatrick and i'm
here to talk to you today
about forensic genetic genealogy a
revolutionary new tool
for solving cold cases
i want to thank lab roots for inviting
me to be the keynote speaker today
and i would also like to thank dr henry
lee for suggesting me
as the keynote speaker i am sure you're
going to get a lot out of my
presentation
here is a mosaic of many people who have
benefited from the forensic genetic
genealogy revolution these
are mostly victims whose perpetrators
have been taken off the streets
but the the mosaic can be expanded
because there are many more victims that
have been helped since i made this
up um and also their families and
friends could be included
because they've been brought answers to
what happened to their loved ones
and keep in mind there are many future
victims that could be included that
aren't going to be
future victims because some of these
criminals have been taken off the
streets
here's the outline of my talk first i'm
going to tell you a little bit
about the history of the forensic
genetic genealogy revolution
i'm going to talk about how why dna can
be used for forensic casework
i'm going to talk to you about autosomal
snip testing how it's used for genealogy
and then how it has to change for
forensic casework
i'm going to give you a couple of very
simple case studies and then
i'm going to summarize everything at the
end
just in case you were living on another
planet at the time
um you the beginning of the
i call it the oh my god era started on
april 25th 2018
when the golden state killer was
identified using
forensic genetic genealogy but even
though this made world news this was
based on a lot of prior
art that had been happening
the chronology of the development of
forensic genetic genealogy is this
in 2000 the first direct-to-consumer dna
testing companies were founded
to provide genetic genealogy to the
genealogy community
dna was regarded as a revolutionary new
tool at the time
because all we had to work with at the
time was just documentation
and often you know the documentation was
wrong
or it may not have existed in the first
place
so dna was promoted to fill that gap
dna may not be able to tell you the
exact relationship between two people
but it's not wrong
so it was a great complement to
documentation in the genealogy toolbox
in 2005 i published a book called
forensic genealogy
it was a hobby book meant to show
genealogists simple ways to identify old
photographs for example or to use
databases or
you know did explain dna to some extent
but the importance of the book
is that it coined the term forensic
genealogy in a way
that's stuck 2006
was the creation of 23andme
they offered a different way to approach
genetic genealogy
instead of why dna which had been in
common use by then
the the the company offered something
called called autosomal snip
testing which could access all the lines
of the family and not just the mail line
2011 was the first case where forensic
genetic genealogy was applied
to generate investigative leads this was
a sarah yarborough homicide out of king
county washington
when i was in seattle for a genealogical
conference
i made an appointment with the seattle
police department to talk to them
about using y dna genetic genealogy to
try and find a last name for their
killer
i was almost laughed out the room
however fortunately there was a woman
the uh director of the dna lab was there
and she
understood what i was talking about so
about six months later she sent me the
ystr
profile on the case and i was able to
compare that to the genetic genealogy
ystr
databases and come up with a possible
last name for
her killer it's a very interesting story
for another time
however that was the first case where
genetic genealogy
was ever applied in 2014
i happened to be in phoenix arizona for
another conference
and i spoke to the phoenix police
department
and i explained how why dna could help
on their cold cases
well they sent me the wide profile for
the phoenix canal murders
i came up with the name miller as a
possible name for their assailant
and well that narrowed down the list of
suspects
from 2000 to just five and the rest is
history
that was the first case ever solved
using genetic genealogy
2017 i co-founded the dna doe project
with margaret press
for identifying john and jane does based
not on why dna but on autosomal snip
testing
uh and and to try and return them to
their families
in 2018 we had our first success story
joseph newton chandler
uh identified as robert ivan nichols now
this didn't you know grab the attention
of the world
as much as the golden state killer did
six weeks later
that was very exciting but the the
joseph chandler case was really the
first case solved using genetic genie
autosomal snip testing genetic genealogy
so back to the beginning in the year
2000
there were several companies formed to
offer genea
dna testing to the genealogy community
the only ones left are family tree dna
and ancestry.com right now that offer
that offer at least some form of testing
of these
and the idea was this that you know the
y
dna went along the male line of the
family with the family name
so that for example it became very
popular with male adoptees
if a man didn't know his birth father's
name he could take a wide dna test
he could put that into some genealogical
database of people
other men who had tested and if his if
he came up with a lot of
matches to the name smith he could be
reasonably sure
that his biological father's was name
was named smith
and you can see the value to forensic
casework there
because a a male adoptee is
really no different from either a john
doe
a male unidentified dead person
or an unknown assailant who's creep
committed a
violent crime code is
the legal form of identification may not
be useful if there's a mixture
it's hard to separate mixtures if you
have male and female together you can
have for example four chromosome tens
and you're not going to know which one
belongs to which person
codis is not helpful if you don't get a
hit in the database you're you know all
dressed up and know where to go
however why dna can be useful in both of
these cases because
in a case of a mixture only the male has
a y
chromosome and you know that has to
belong to him
and when you don't have a hidden codis
you could try matching
your dna to the genetic genealogy
databases
and see if you could come up with the
last name now it this is not
as say powerful as kodus you can't
normally make a one-to-one match like in
codis but
it's better than nothing you know you
can at least match your killer to
a an extended family
there are about 8 000 genetic genealogy
dna studies out there right now
i estimate this i have not um counted
them
there are many um studies that are
dedicated to last names to ethnic
backgrounds
to geo geographical um
groups to descendants from famous people
um and going and looking for matches to
a wide profile can be very time
consuming except that we've developed
proprietary software that has automated
a lot of that
and the point is that if you get a match
between
a forensic y profile and
you know a genetic genealogy genealogist
or something in a gene
genetic genealogy databases that
provides you with a possible last name
for your killer or your john doe
statistics about uh why str databases
this is from the end of 2019
they're a little bit larger now the
number of y profiles
is about 250 000 public profiles
there are more in the proprietary
company databases but this is what can
be
accessed publicly through public
websites
the number of databases is about 8 000
and the largest ethnic database is the
scottish database which right now is
probably close to eleven thousand two
hundred
um the largest surname project not
surprisingly is smith
with four thousand nearly forty 100 back
then
it's probably like more like 4 200 now
a little bit about why dna about why
strs
when the foreign when the genealogy
companies that genetic genealogy direct
to consumer companies
were you know building up their test
panels
they borrowed ystr's from forensics
they used the same ones so that meant
that you could compare
a wide profile from a forensic case to a
genetic genealogy
database and see if you could find
matches they were the same markers
and and the benefit is that you did not
need to retest the evidence
you could just an agency could send me a
pdf or an
excel spreadsheet and that would work
the value of a y dna match
was to produce a possible last name for
the unknown
the genealogy is usually not
useful um and this makes sense because
say in the case of the phoenix canal
murders when i came up with the name
miller
that man matched six millers in that
database
and two were from germany four were from
the uk
and they didn't know how they matched
each other so
it's not going to be possible for you to
take you know somebody else
and match it against six people that
don't know how they are related
the genealogy is not very useful as a
rule
sometimes i can tell there are tools
that i can't go over i don't have enough
time to explain but there are ways
to determine ethnicity from why str
profiles so on occasion when i've
offered
you know this guy is say
african-american or asian
the for the next question question is
what does he look like
you know what is he a light-skinned
african-american
dark-skinned and my answer is i can't
tell you
because why scr's don't give any
information on appearance
you should also keep in mind the
possibility of an adoption
or a name change or an illegitimacy in
the family
we call that a non-fraternity event or a
misattributed fraternity
and in such a case the legal somebody's
legal name
will not match their biological name
i'd like to give you a case study a very
simple case study
simple but illuminating this is the
allison fellman homicide
from february 2015 in scottsdale arizona
allison was murdered in her home she was
strangled
she was also experienced blunt force
trauma to her head and she was except
sexually assaulted with a beer bottle
this was a very messy crime scene
uh you know the police talked to her
family her friends there's a boyfriend
in the picture
uh the neighbors anybody she worked with
and
nothing happened all the leads went cold
in june 2015
the scottsdale police department sent me
the wide dna profile on the case
and this was interesting because i came
up with several names
that were possibilities meacham ferguson
and moody and there were i think a
couple of other ones that were just
singletons just had one match
these were the number of exact matches i
found in each of those
surname databases i don't also include
that they had several
one-step neighbors where there was one
marker off which i normally take into
the calculation
um but you know of these three meacham
was the top name
the police department looked in their
data files and their case files for
people of any of these names and came up
empty so
the case went cold again however
a couple of years later the police
department that
got an okay to do a familial search this
was the first familial search that was
allowed in the state of arizona
and this means that the uh codis profile
was was searched in the codis database
but not for exact matches it was
searched for near matches that could be
very close family members as the
perpetrator
when the police department did this the
results came
hit on a man who had been in prison
since 1994.
obviously his dna was in codis
um he was in prison so he could not be
the perpetrator
but he had a brother who had been
arrested for felony dui
and when that happened the case had been
dismissed but the brother again had been
rearrested
and in the course of that process he had
given a blood sample
however it had only been tested for
blood alcohol content and not for dna
and when they tested it for dna they
found
that there was a codis match uh
to enl mitchum so i use this just to
illustrate the fact that you know
genetic genealogy had the potential of
working and so did familial
searching either one they're both very
uh
very powerful investigative techniques
the reason one worked and the other
didn't was because of the contents of
the database
it could have happened the other way
around that genetic genealogy why dna
could have
you know produced they could have had
somebody in the case file named mitchum
or meacham
and the case would have been solved in
2015
but unfortunately that was not the case
and familial search on the other hand
had that match produced that match that
led to a suspect
so it could have been you know familial
search could have come up empty and we
did genetic genealogy they're both
valuable investigative tools
mr mitchum was charged with first-degree
murder and burglary
he may face the death penalty and
as common in death penalty cases this
trial has been postponed
i'd like to talk about autosomal snip
testing for genealogy this is a
this is the other way of doing what is
this is commonly called forensic genetic
genealogy
although that can also include y dna
as we've discussed first let me say this
let me explain how what we do in
genealogy differs from what
what law enforcement does with autosomal
dna
law enforcement uses the codis markers
which are 12 pieces of well
characterized real estate on the genome
they are the markers are called
autosomal strs
or short tandem repeats the
key key thing the key word is short
which means
these markers can be short and long they
have some
length to them and they are used for the
legal form
of identification on the other hand
genetic genealogy uses autosomal snips
instead of 20 markers they use six
hundred thousand and nine hundred
thousand
snips snips up points on the genome
and you can you can remember that
because the s stands for
single and it's not a question anymore
does this profile match what's already
in the database
what steps are used for is estimating
relationships
because the more snips two people share
the closer they are related
and the fewer snips they shared the more
distant they are related
in in briefly this is the difference
codis uses 20 strs
snip testing uses 600 000 to 900
000 snips codis is good for immediate
relatives
and familial searches but snip testing
is good to fit
cousins are more distant i solved a case
recently based on 8th to 10th cousins
qotis is a legal form of identification
but
snip testing autosomal snip testing is
only good for generating leads
codas can give you a match or an
exclusion but sniff testing
testing can give you ethnicity
geographic information
family history it can even tell you if
someone's jewish sometimes
so it can give you the information on
religion
so yeah i solved the case recently
because it was a jane doe case
and when we uploaded it to the date
write database
all her matches were from maine so she
was from maine and it
in that case went very quick
a little bit about autosomal snip
testing
this kind of analysis came from the
biomedical industry
so therefore forensics forensic labs
crime labs
can't produce this kind of data
so to use autosomal snip testing
for forensic cases you have to retest
the evidence
if you don't have any more evidence
don't have any more dna on the case
you can't do this you have to hope you
have a y
profile and then you could use the y dna
that i've just explained
but if you don't have a y profile and
you don't have any more
dna then you're out of luck
you cannot use the codis markers
you cannot use the standard conventional
markers used by the
legal community so what generally
happens when you do a case like this
there's
usually the code codus has been tried
there's no hit
using the codous markers in the codis
databases
then you go to genetic genealogy and if
you're successful and you do
identify a suspect you still have to go
and get dna from that suspect to
see if he's a match codis match to the
crime scene
data you always have to go back to codis
there are four major direct to consumer
testing companies that
offer autosomal snip testing this has
become
wildly popular in our community and
right now there's probably about 30
million people who have taken
a test from one or more of these
companies
the databases have grown considerably in
recent years
you can see to the left in 2012 there
just wasn't a whole lot going on
but as time went on and more success
stories came out in the news
the testing autosomal snoop testing
became very popular
and around the time when the golden
state killer and the dna doe project are
getting formed
there was about 10 million people in
those databases and there was a
over a 50 50 chance that if an adoptee
used tested with one or more of these
companies he would find his birth family
so this became very interesting to the
forensic community
the way this works for genealogy is very
simple
you're watching tv one night and you
order a dna test
you see a commercial you send your you
know get online send your credit card in
you receive a kit in the mail with a
little cup and you spit in the cup
you seal it up and you mail it back to
the company
a few weeks later your results come in
the mail
here here is just an abbreviated uh
idea of my my friend andrew eiser's
results first you get
a list of your matches maybe with a name
or maybe a birthday
you get an estimate of how close that
person is related to you
and then you get something else whatever
they posted on their profile
they will you know say the names in
their family perhaps or geographic
locations
maybe some other things
you own your data so there's one more
thing you can do
with it you can download it
to your hard drive and you can upload it
to
a website called gedmatch now why would
you want to do that
what is genmatch jet match is a third
party public website
it is a database with tools genmatch
does not do
any testing it is not affiliated with
any direct to consumer companies and it
accepts
uploads from all of the companies so
therefore if i
tested with ancestry.com
you know normally i just would see
ancestry matches
but if i upload my data to jet match i
can start to find
matches who tested with 23 and me and
etc
i won't find i can't access the 23andme
database
but i can find dna cousins among 23andme
people that did the same thing i did and
uploaded to gedmatch
it's meant chipnot just meant as a
playground or a sandbox for us to play
with our dna genealogists have
contributed
all kinds of tools that you can't find
anywhere else
the large direct to consumer companies
are interested in other things
you know selling tests and providing a
few tools but this platform is meant
it was developed by us for us
and there's so much else you can do with
it that you can't do
using one of the big companies
jeb match now has you know over a
million people
maybe 1.5 million or so we don't know
for sure
and it's growing i put an asterisk there
because not
all all all users are
open to law enforcement uh the default
when you upload to jet matches your kit
is opted out and
and law enforcement can't can't see your
results
um you have to go into your settings and
opt in and
up to now about 350 000 of those people
have opted in
and about 80 of new users opt in
here are some of the high level tools
with gedmatch you have a one-to-many
tool where you can look at your list of
matches
you can look at a tool that provides you
with an admixture breakout
that what you see there is typical of
caucasian europeans this might even
be my own uh breakout the the red
section is normally the biggest because
the database is biased toward caucasian
europeans
um the red represents you know
north uh northern european the british
isles
ireland um southern scandinavia and
western france
the orange is more continental europe
and the other colors are splashes
of the mediterranean or other places in
europe
maybe north africa the other tool
is are your parents related this tool is
useful
in uh determining something called
consent annuity that is
how intermarried a population somebody
comes from
this is especially useful for forensics
because
um if it comes up that the parents are
heavily related
that's an indication of where this
person might be from
such as you know west virginia it's you
know famous for
everybody being married to everyone else
um another place is appalachia
another place is southern louisiana and
surprisingly another very intermarried
place
is the four corners area in the in the
west
this is because the spanish moved out in
the 1600s and they stayed
they intermarried with the native
americans out there
and they're still there so this are your
parents related tools kind of funny
sounding but
it's very useful for forensics
here is a an example of one too many how
that works
you get the information you get from the
one to many
is you get a kid number associated with
every match
you get um a estimate of how much dna
you share with everyone in terms of
centimorgans
you get an estimate of how many
generations you go back
uh to find your common ancestor with
each person
you get a name or a screen name for each
person
and you get an email address for each
person
so you can contact them an example here
would be
this woman ann who appeared on andy's
matches a few slides earlier
was is a third cousin and in fact we
contacted her worked her genealogy and
she was a third cousin
so how does that change when you start
using all this for forensics
well as as you've seen for genealogy
the way it works is you order you spit
you mail
you get your results and you upload to
gen match to use
all those really great tools so what do
you do to make it work for forensics
how do you how do you order a 23andme
kit
for a john or jane doe or for a rapist
well you actually don't those direct to
consumer companies do not
accept forensic cases um as a rule
the top the biggest ones don't um
so how come we can do this
well this is how it works how do you
cheat let me tell you how to circumvent
those
direct to consumer testing companies
in 2017 there was a man whose father had
died
he had wanted to test his father using
23 million ancestry but he couldn't do
that
when his father when father passed away
so he went to the hospital got a tissue
sample from his father's biopsy he sent
it to an independent lab
and he provided them a copy of his own
23 million ancestry results
and he asked them can you make something
data that looks just like this from my
father's tissue sample
and they said sure so the lab
generated direct to consumer
consumer-like results for his father's
tissue sample
and he uploaded those to jed match and
it worked like a charm
all the relationship predicted by jed
match were
just perfect for all the relatives of
his that were already on the site
so that showed we didn't need those
companies anymore
and
the implication for forensics is obvious
as of early 2017
it was almost like law enforcement was
on one side of the
dna fence and genetic genealogy testing
companies were on the other
those testing companies have an enormous
amount of data that would have been very
helpful to identify the golden state
killer but they weren't giving it up
so as i said the first step was that we
discovered how to generate
ancestry-like 23andme like data
using an independent lab and we could
upload that to gedmatch and when that
gate opened that was the beginning of
the forensic genetic genealogy
revolution
so let's talk about a couple of case
studies
the way we deal with
the genetic genealogy identification
process is like this
you upload your data to jet match it's
generated by an independent lab it's
gone through bioinformatics whatever you
have that
pseudo ancestry 23andme data whatever
and when you upload it to gedmatch
you're going to have a list of matches
you don't know who these people
are so the first step is to identify
each of your top matches and start
building family trees for each one of
those
as you continue you're going to start to
see these trees connect
because of each one of those matches
is related to your your perp or your
john doe
then in some form they're going to start
relating to each other
ideally you're going to find that the
matches form
two groups that are each related
internal to the group but are not
related to the other group and these
represent
the the family trees of the two parents
of your unknown
your task at that point is to find a
member of one group who married a member
of the other group
and one of their children is your
suspect or your john doe
here is a very simple case study showing
you how this works
this is the murder of jack fay he was
murdered in may
2013 in warwick rhode island
he was a 66 year old retired pro close
to work he was a very
quiet guy he was divorced he was on good
terms with his wife
his ex-wife but they didn't really see
each other that much
they had a daughter in common you know
he was not
a very active lively person but he ran
uh daily he ran through the city park
and sometime early morning on may 17th
somebody attacked
him and his body was found about a day
and a half later in a trash barrel
he was bludgeoned stabbed the crime
scene was very messy
there was a lot of dna belonging to him
and to the killer
this is a picture a screenshot of the
area where he was killed or at least the
parkway was killed
and you can see that in early morning
especially in may the sun's not up this
is a very dark place
probably pretty dangerous
we got his data generated by that
independent lab
we uploaded to the chad match and this
is what it looked like
and this is unusual for an experienced
forensic
genealogist because when you look at
that
the the over half of that
profile is mediterranean and as i said
to you earlier the databases are biased
to caucasian europeans so
automatically you see we're starting to
develop our two
groups that we're looking for
we have other tools i can't go over
right now but there's a way of
taking y dna uh autosomal snip testing
nystrs and developing the population
group somebody comes from
called the haplogroup and in this case
this was haplogroup
j2a1 you don't have to know what that
stands for you just have to know that's
the name of the group
and that group is a a eastern
mediterranean group
centered i think what looks like
you know lebanon or turkey um
but when i looked at the closest y dna
matches
i came up with only one match to the
name azevedo
which is portuguese so i told the
detectives
i can't guarantee it's acevedo but i'm
almost sure it's portuguese and that
would be
on the other side of the mediterranean
we did the same thing for the
mitochondrial dna as indicative of the
female haplogroup
and we came up with a middle eastern
group that was associated with turkey
and iran and so on
okay step one identify each match match
one was named lewis
match two was late named lynn marie
lewis happened to be portuguese lynn
marie happened to be syrian
now this took a lot of work but i'm
going to explain it only a few minutes
this was a very tough case
um we started building lewis's tree we
started building
lynn marie's tree on and on we got and
then we came across
a group a a a match
called dolores dorothea and we built her
tree out
and we found out she had a cousin named
norma ethel
and norma ethel the first thing is to
find the two groups that are not related
to each other
uh norma ethel actually married uh
lewis and so there you had a portuguese
caucasian group forming
and their child was named michael
michael
portuguese caucasian married lynne marie
who we saw with syrian a minute ago and
they had a child
michael anthony swords jr who was
portuguese syrian with some caucasian
mixed in
and that's a very unusual combination
so the detectives moved in they asked
him to give
a sample of his dna which he did this
was very interesting because
in in researching this man they found
out
that the day after the murder he was
found trying to get on a plane
uh going to pakistan tsa
noticed him he was he had a very thick
black beard
and they they flagged him and they sent
him home
well it turned out he wasn't anything to
do with al qaeda he was just strange
strange guy
he had mental problems he did fine if he
took his medication
if he went off the medication he didn't
do so good
they called him in the station he
voluntarily gave a dna
sample and at that point he's free to go
but he went and he sat in the lobby of
the police station
and the police while they were
processing processing his dna to see if
there was a codis match to crime scene
dna
they were watching him on the
surveillance camera in the lobby
hoping he wouldn't leave but he just sat
there so
they when it they achieved a match where
the code is it a coda's hit they
just went out into the lobby arrested
him and brought him in the rest is
history
the second uh case study is the buckskin
girl which we did under the dna doe
project
boxing girl was found in april 1981
in a rural area around troy ohio
she apparently and that's was a probably
a
body dump out in an agricultural field
uh she had died by strangulation only
about a day and a half
earlier she's called buckskin girl
because
of the jacket she was found wearing at
the time
um the case went cold people had seen
her around town but nobody knew who she
was
so there was really no way to identify
her in 2016 however a renewed effort was
put into
finding out who she was pollen analysis
was done
isotope analysis and a new artist
rendition was
was created by the national center for
missing and exploited children
pollen analysis indicated she had been
out like in an
arid dry area like the southwest united
states
out in arizona and california isotope
analysis showed
agreed with that but also showed she had
been down to
the fort worth area twice in the month
or so before she died
um so there was a lot of information
about
generally where she had been
you know but there was really nothing
that could lead to identification at
that time
she was buried in 1981 and that's the
way the case stayed
until uh 2017
early 18 when the dna doe project got it
and we generated her you know autosomal
snip data
using an independent lab we uploaded it
to gedmatch and this was her ethnicity
report
you can see she's caucasian european she
has that big red
wedge uh she has the orange indicating
continental europe and she's got
a splash of mediterranean in her plus a
little bit of sub-saharan africa
here is here are her matches her
one-to-many results
her top match was a woman whose nickname
was sam
sam match 415 centimorgans
to buckskin girl so what in the world
does that mean
what is the center morgan first of all a
centimorgan is a unit of dna
the higher the number of centimorgans
two people share
the more closely they are related and
conversely
the lower the number they share the more
distantly they are related
the highest two people can share is
about 3 700 and that would be between a
parent and a child
now to find out what the 400 what 15
centimorgan means we have a calculator
we use called dna painter
it's called it it's drawn from the
shared cinema organ project tool
so going to that website popping in
415.4
centimorgans into the calculator the
results came in with a very high
probability
of that one of these being the
relationship between
buckskin girl and sam so we knew who sam
was
and that's going to help us find out who
her cousin is
sam was i think you know one generation
or 20 years older than buckskin girl
so you have to immediately eliminate uh
great greats from the list
um what's left is either a half first
cousin or
first cousin once removed
to remind you a first cousin in case you
don't remember is the child of your
uncle or your aunt you share a
set of grandparents with your first
cousin you have a common grandma
and a common grandpa when that cousin
has a child
that will be your first cousin once
removed
so your grandma and grandpa will be that
person's
great-grandma and great-grandpa
when you have a kid then that kid
is second cousins to your cousin's kid
in other words your kid and that other
kid
have common great grandpa
and great grandma
another thing to define for you
before we go further is what what a half
cousin is
suppose grandpa was married twice a
child from the other marriage
is going to be your half uncle or your
half aunt
he only shares one parent with your in
this diagram your dad
when he has a kid that's going to be
your half first cousin
because you only share one grandparent
in this diagram is your grandpa but you
have different grandmas
so first cousin half first cousin gets
married and has
a kid that is going to be your half
first cousin once removed
and you your grandpa is going to be his
great grandfather
but you that's all you share you don't
share grandma or great grandma's at all
and when you have a kid then your kid
is half second cousin to the other
child and those two individuals
share only a great grandfather
in this diagram only one grandparent but
not the other
so let's go back to buckskin
let's try half first cousin there's sam
there's her father her parents or
grandparents let's see if grandpa was
married more than once
suppose that that second union had i
well let's say a half aunt it could be a
half uncle as well
and when that half and a half uncle had
a child that would be
sam's half first cousin because they
shared grandpas
but they didn't share grandmas so we
looked into sam's family tree
and we could not find any evidence that
grandpa
had been married more than once the
other possibility
is first cousin once removed this is how
this works here's sam
here's sam's let's go sam's mother but
you have to look at mom
and dad's side but i'm gonna cut to the
chase
as they say in hollywood we looked at
her parents we looked at her
grandparents
and then we started coming down the
family tree we looked at
uh that set of grandparents
had one son and three daughters the son
would be
sam's uncle sam's uncle
had several children including
a son named john sozeman that would be
sam's first cousin we're looking for
first cousins once removed
so we want john susan's children
we looked at his children he had six
children by two wives
and we found proof of life for five of
them
the sixth one we could find nothing on
when we went to ancestry to look up more
information about that person
we came across a family tree martial and
north king sozumen
was in that tree she was born in 1959
in biloxi mississippi and when the the
the death was listed as missing assumed
dead you can't miss that we had
identified buxton girl
girl in only four hours this tree was
posted by
sam a cousin but it had actually
originally been posted by
mark marsha's father he was the family
genealogist and this
this was kind of like a note in a bottle
to the genealogical community
to help find his daughter and i'm sorry
to tell you
but uh john susman died two or three
months before
we found this we identified his daughter
we notified the miami county sheriff's
office
we always work with the agency we do not
go to the family directly
he called marsha's mom down in
little rock arkansas she was in her 80s
she was not doing very well at the time
she had a son and a daughter who had
died
and actually the sheriff's office
contacted
the son of the son i think you know
because they felt
more comfortable with with contacting a
younger person
and he told his mother what had happened
with marcia
um and the woman
had had not moved in 37 years she had
not changed her phone number
because she was wanted to make it easy
for her daughter to come home
her daughter had been known for
hitchhiking a lot just taking off
hitchhiking coming back later and so 37
years
had passed and she was still waiting for
her to come home
she came home but it wasn't you know the
way she had hoped
here's a two pictures of marsha that
were provided by her
mother and you can see that artist
rendition is just
very good
the case was in namus it was clicked in
as
being closed and it's gone
marcia now is laid to rest under a stone
with her own name
uh the family came out and gave a
memorial service her mother was not able
to attend because she was
quite sick but there she is god's child
in summary let's go back to the mosaic
this is what it means
these are just a fraction of the people
who have benefited from the revolution
there's a lot of controversy about
privacy versus public safety but when
you look at these faces
just any one of them could be you or me
so i know which side of the fence i fall
on
thank you for having me i'd like to
acknowledge all of these
individuals and organizations that have
helped uh
develop the the techniques for doing
this that have helped
push forward the revolution here is my
contact
information um if you have any questions
i'll be glad to hear from you
thank you very much